its names are many from the golden
perfect to the lasso of hestia
but its purpose is singular it compels
those within its bonds to tell the truth
where did this fabulous rope come from
well we're here to divine the truth of
wonder woman's lasso
the lasso began as part of the goddess
aphrodite's
magical girdle an item bestowed upon the
amazons that granted them
strength and immortality queen hippolyta
intrigued by its properties
instructed her craftswoman matala to
forge a golden rope from it
matala did so creating the very first
iteration of wonder woman's wonderful
lasso
it was a finely wrought golden chain
that didn't in fact
compel its subject to tell the truth but
to obey it was unbreakable
magically elastic capable of binding
groups of people
and once coded in chemicals of amazonian
design
was able to transform diana's civilian
clothes
into her wonder woman costume then dc's
landmark event
crisis on infinite earths took place
wonder woman's lasso was left
relatively unchanged saved for two major
alterations
it now compelled the truth rather than
obedience
and it was no longer an amazonian design
this post-crisis
lasso was instead forged by hyphestus
god of metallurgy himself
from the golden girdle of gaia tempered
in the fires of pestia
but that wasn't the end of the lasso's
changes as the new 52 reboots of the dc
universe changed the legendary tool
still further
nowadays the lasso is known to the
amazons as the golden perfect
a gift from the gods passed down through
the generations
it's a symbol of sacred trust that of
the amazons and the gods
and the gods in the amazons only an
amazon of purest heart can wield it
making diana a perfect candidate
generally speaking
the lasso's powers seem fairly
straightforward wonder woman raps a bad
guy in it
bad guy has to tell the truth about his
evil scheme and the heroes rush off to
stop it with their newfound knowledge
but truth is a slippery slope and wonder
woman's deeply held sense of compassion
will never allow her to settle for
convenience
when there's honesty to be had luckily
the lasso's powers are flexible enough
to account for this
under the umbrella of truth the lasso
can do everything from dispelling
illusions
induced by hallucinatory gas to allowing
people to communicate openly beyond a
stubborn language barrier
in the recent year 1 storyline a
neophyte wonder woman
dazzled by the delights and depredations
of man's world
used the lasso then still new to her to
accomplish
both of these feats when she etta candy
steve trevor and dr barbara and minerva
all held the lasso at once they were
able to communicate despite diana's
inability to then speak
english soon after an insanity-inducing
poison turned a squad of helpless men
into manic murderers with the lasso
diana was able to dispel the poison's
effects immediately
and discern the men's innocence truth
might need to be delivered as a magical
antidote or
immersive immediate language course but
the lasso will always be able to fit the
bill
despite its amazing powers wonder
woman's lasso is
in fact a simple lasso sure it's an
unbreakable one that can stretch
shrink and form complicated nets and
snares but it's a rope with a loop tied
to it
wonder woman uses it often in this
manner throwing it to catch midair
villains and rampaging animals alike
or when a disaster comes along the lasso
is useful for towing unlucky victims to
high ground
the shore or beyond a fire's reach in
the golden and silver ages however
wonder woman explored the lasso's
physical properties to the furthest
extent
as the character wasn't originally
capable of flight she could twirl
the lasso furiously enough to create air
currents she could float on wonder woman
was practically a cowgirl during this
era
so skillfully did she wield her magical
chain gal gadot might be able to unleash
devastating shock waves from her
bracelets but we'd like to see her give
someone a serious earache with a
particularly
fierce twirl of the lasso confronting
foes with upsetting truths has its uses
more than once diana has used the
lasso's powers to force those within its
bonds to face a secret that motivates
them to do ill
or to face consequences they'd prefer to
ignore in 2008's wonder woman number 15
diana confronted captain nazi an old foe
looking to bring the third reich back to
life
seeking to learn of his plan to invade
themyscira
diana wrapped him in the lasso and
discovered his past as well
facing his abusive childhood brought him
to tears
which had the dual effect of stopping
his assault and forcing him to lose
faith in his campaign
similarly during george perez's run on
wonder woman
diana stopped and emboldened aries at
the point when all
seemed lost in the lasso's coils he saw
the result of his quest to cover the
earth in conflict and bloodshed
a barren rock void of followers and thus
void of the discord that fueled him
the abject loneliness of this vision
didn't just compel him to retreat
but it actually wrenched tears from his
eyes in the end it wasn't violence that
stopped either of these terrible
villains
but the truth that was lurking within
their own hearts
unfortunately not all who seek wonder
woman's destruction can be constrained
by the lasso
genocide a villain envisioned by wonder
woman writer gail simone as
being the heroine's antithesis actually
used the lasso to further her
own depraved aims a superpowered
juggernaut
created from both diana's corpse
retrieved from the future
and soil from the sites of 20th century
killing fields
genocide was a ruthless golem of
murderous intent
used to further the aims of aries the
cheetah and other members of wonder
woman's rogues gallery
in her first assault upon the amazon
genocide was actually
able to steal the lasso and take it back
to her terrible masters
who surgically implanted it within
genocide's body
twisted into serving horrible aims the
lasso imbued genocide with incredible
power
suddenly she could overthrow the will of
green lantern corps members
manipulate those around her into
disabling despair
and exude a general aura of rage and
hopelessness
all reason and rationality could be
overthrown in one terrible flood of
psychic energy from the lasso that
genocide had
buried in her own flesh though diana was
able to retrieve it and genocide was
scattered to the winds
the memory of what the lasso was capable
of when put to
evil ends was not so easily forgotten
being an object and not a power she
herself is imbued with
wonder woman can use the lasso upon
herself
rarely does she need to employ this
ability she makes a point of being
honest with herself and others from the
get-go
but it's come in handy more often than
you might think
usually this comes in the form of diana
wrapping herself in it to prove
she speaks truthfully sometimes it's a
private practice meant to reconnect the
heroin to her roots
and her mission but occasionally she
needs the lasso in a moment of extreme
crisis
and those are often the most spectacular
uses of all
during 2016's year one storyline wonder
woman was exposed to a fear and rage
inducing gas
plunged into a mindless fury she
promised to anoint the men of this new
world with the blood they seemed to
crave
but clarity managed to shine through and
she managed to grab hold of her lasso
and wrap it around her own body head to
toe
as tightly as possible her mind cleared
of anger and despair
and she dispersed her own insanity in a
dazzling blaze of power
crying out this is not true
the day was saved the villains were
caught and wonder woman
fresh from themselves shores had
discovered just
how much of a difference she and her
wonderful lasso could make in this
strange new world
just as wonder woman has her lasso the
girls who've taken on the mantle of
wonder
girl must have lassos of their own but
they don't have lassos of truth
instead they have lassos of very
different powers
suited for very different heroines donna
troy
a wonder girl of many divergent origin
stories
wields a silver blue lasso with as much
dexterity as the heroine she takes her
name from
in 2010's justice league of america
number 44
she named it the lasso of persuasion as
she told the demon etragan bound within
it
anyone whose will is less than hers has
to do what she tells them
and her will is iron cassie sans mark
the second wonder girl
wields a very different lasso the lasso
of lightning
this lasso is uniquely connected to her
as a daughter of zeus
channeling her godly father's legendary
lightning through its
unbreakable bonds moreover as was
revealed when the witch cersei had the
lasso of lightning under her control in
2006's wonder woman number four
it's also capable of inducing rage
whether it's truth
persuasion or lightning the lassos of
the dc universe are not to be trifled
with
if there's one thing you know about
wonder woman's creator william moulton
marston it's probably that he invented
the lie detector
but this nugget of common knowledge
isn't precisely true
marston created the systolic blood
pressure test not the polygraph itself
and he never accomplished his goal of
introducing it to the court system
he still managed to make good on his
contribution appeared in a series of
gillette advertisements
and he got many of his ideas to the
public through the comics he'd become
best known for
but the common understanding of
marston's invention having something to
do with wonder woman's lasso of truth is
solidly wrong
especially since his rendition of the
lasso compelled obedience
instead of truth-telling in fact marston
saw wonder woman's lasso as symbolizing
something very different
the natural allure he believed all women
possessed that the world would do well
to heed
as detailed in jill the poor's landmark
book the secret history of wonder woman
marston saw the amazons as ruling
through natural
charm grace wisdom and strength the
lasso merely got people to accept them
as
rightful leaders a little more quickly
than they would have otherwise
larson is really endlessly fascinating
there's some kind of almost
not an effort in american culture that
he doesn't have a hand in in the first
half of the 20th century
truth was important sure but accepting
amazonian guidance was the real path to
a just and peaceful world
that's a little harder to turn into a
sound bite than the man who invented the
lie detector also invented the lasso of
truth
the lasso of truth is crucially
unbreakable
what good would it be otherwise in a
world of razor-sharp batarangs and
beings of god-like strength
wonder woman can't go around having it
snapped by any old bad guy in a
super-powered
exoskeleton no as befitting a tool
forged by the gods the lasso is
unbreakable
though it's always climactic and heralds
an enormous change of stakes
the lasso has in fact been broken before
sometimes it's the result of having its
connection to truth weakened on the
conceptual level
bizarro representing the reversal of all
things
was able to break it in 2003's batman
superman wonder woman
trinity series but in 2003's superman
red sun wonder woman broke it herself in
a desperate attempt to save superman
occasionally it's broken through diana's
own weakness
for example her dismay at learning a
truth she couldn't handle
in 1997's jla number 62
ripped the lasso apart through the sheer
force of the quandary at hand
naturally it's always returned to
wholeness but the lasso
as its mistress is not invulnerable
which provides readers with a wealth of
stories
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one